I don't know how I'm going to keep this Lonerbox bridge intact
at all, to be honest with you. >> I think you should be
in prison. I think you should be like tried or something cuz
you're scum. Can I interest you in dying for Israel to own the
libs? Can I [laughter] Hey, fight a war for Israel to own the
libs? >> work. This just might work.
The Trump admin >> You should be thankful that we're calling
for investigations and not [__] gallows,
>> What's up? That must [music] be Queen Man. I just saw
you chat.
Respect to this guy, bro.
Dude, I I made this joke earlier today in a Discord. It's like
I swear to God these like propagandists, when I see them, it's
like are they are they trying to convince me? Are they trying
to convince me that QAnon was right? Is that their goal? Anyway.
>> It is crazy, man. You do just say like the most
like just sickening, sociopathic,
you know,
view of the world for so many people.
Especially Americans, unfortunately some
>> I heard you were attacking Lonerbox all day today. I
was I was getting at >> [__] Lonerbox stream?
No, I was just It was basically came up like a few times. I was
talking about Iran. I ended up watching some of the H3 thing
cuz it's just like sickening watching them like do the both sides
and like the difference in energy.
It's like this guy will like spaz out over so-and-so's about,
you know, playing you know, spin soft on Hamas or whatever. And
then it's like, "Oh, the a the whole school for the kids has
just been killed." And that seems kind of bad. I think Well,
I do think that was probably the hardest he pushed back though,
so you got to give him that a little bit. Like Like Ethan was
trying to basically suggest that they built that like on a military
base. He's like, "No, I think it was like actually hundreds of
meters away." Right? Like half a kilometer away probably. My
my brain keeps telling me that someone like Hexath has loosened
rules of engagement to allow someone like that to happen. I don't
know why because it seems like the consensus now is that it was
more likely an American than an Israeli strike because of how
each side has responded to the claims. It could have also been
either. It could have been a stray missile from Iran. It could
have been an interception and that's why it fell short, but to
me it points like either more likely America, but maybe America
or Israel just being a little bit too loosey-goosey with their
targeting, which is quite which is just criminal.
I don't know why the fact that it was the first wave of strikes,
why is he if your first wave of strikes is near a
why why are you doing that? Yeah, he did go he was correct in
stuff. He was not like he wasn't saying, you know, the truth,
but it wasn't um
you know, I think this [__] should legit be treated
like I think if you're if you are playing defense with this [__]
you should be treated terribly. You should be. Well, it's like
I'm I'm not sincerely going and saying like of course you know,
of course Khamenei like cracking on protesters or something.
That's his right as like a I'm not going to like run defense
for his actions. >> No, I literally no no one is out here
nobody nobody nobody aside from like
the most third worldest leftists on Twitter that have no people.
Nobody is out here saying
the Ayatollah wasn't even that bad. Why people why do people
hate the Ayatollah so much? >> Although I will say from
what I'm hearing about his son, who is the like head of the SS
like the Iranian SS, who's now been elected supreme leader of
the country, Hey, but you know, >> compared to that guy
if that [snorts] guy had his way, you know, they would have gone
to every every single protester's house and shoot them, not just
like the rowdy ones. They would have like like that guy's probably
got a list of people that he's going to get rid of at some point
in the very near future,
I don't think they killed the moderate that yes, they
I'm just saying whenever you do this
So, we're just reading this article and even in here they're
like we don't really know how this is going to go. If you kill
Khamenei like it depends on who else gets killed. Here's like
a bunch of options and even Trump said like those weren't the
options. I truly believe Khamenei's son was like down the list
quite a bit. Like he has a lot of people don't like him in the
country. Maybe if you're one of the people who wants like fracturing
the IRGC this could maybe be good. It's going to be horrible
for the people who live in Iran for the short period of time
that he's supreme leader
but you might actually be able to get fracturing this way, right?
I'm like just waiting for boots on the ground to install the
MEK. I'm like I would sketch of fair just that's what's going
to happen.
Um I think the moment I saw Pompeo shelling it Dude, you should
watch there's another there's so much you should you should watch
it's really good. Someone told me I should tell you to watch
the Adam Curtis documentary
I watched on stream a while ago.
Hold on you need to lean into the mic. Um The Adam Adam Curtis
documentary
hyper normalization.
But uh there's there's like an interview with uh
Mike Pompeo by the same podcast that did that Ashrafi interview
I sent you.
yeah I feel like Pompeo is just like kind of
Pompeo is kind of on the pulse of where shit's headed foreign
policy wise.
So correct me if I'm wrong. Pompeo wasn't the guy who's like
good luck to the Iranian protesters and the Mossad agents walking
beside them. >> I think that was Pompeo. I think that was
Pompeo. Are you saying it was Huckabee? I thought that was Pompeo.
I thought it was Pompeo too. I just couldn't come up with the
name and then people told me it was um
I feel like people told me it was >> you I heard you say
probably from chat that it was Huckabee. I was thinking I thought
it was Pompeo
uh that said that. Yeah yeah it was Pompeo. It was Pompeo who
said that.
>> Yeah. So I know I Pompeo you know I think Pompeo just
kind of knows what's going on. Just kind of it is, to be
Well, he was >> No, I don't I don't like [laughter] the
guy. I don't agree with him. >> for Trump or something,
right? No, he was secretary of state. Yeah, yeah, he was like
yeah, he was in the first cabinet. But yeah, it's so I I don't
I don't like him. I wouldn't say I hate his ideas, but I do think
he
is like he's in the mindset >> into the administration.
It's like if you hear Bannon or something say >> Yeah,
exactly. Yeah, yeah, exactly, exactly.
Well, like I Yeah, it's funny cuz um He's definitely going to
run in the primary as well, 100%. He's going to go run in the
Republican primary.
You think so? Yeah. >> Interesting. Man.
Did I send you this this like network analysis for the like astroturfing?
I've not read the thing on stream yet. I read a little bit of
it. I just ran into like It's like bad when I can see that a
guy who's doing like open and like completely dishonest misinfo,
disinfo on October 7th
is like named in this thing and a prominent part of this whole
operation to like astroturf the Monero's opinions online.
I I get headaches, man. I just get
Yeah, dude, they're all shocked. Even Trump's saying the show
ain't going to be leader. Like, come on now. The show ain't happening.
Jeb's I watched some of the Jeb stuff on stream earlier. That
guy belongs in a
He's I do I mean, his uh he's not got a what do you call it?
An impartial view of it, right? He's just like obviously biased.
Yeah. He's Iranian diaspora. Um Obviously, he's probably heard
really bad stories from Iran. Like, I've no doubt that a lot
of people in Iran really hate the regime, right? >> you
totally embarrassed yourself when you start doing the whole towel
head towel head as a Iranian diaspora that's
Okay. I'm writing you off.
Yeah, hold on.
What do I do? Have you watched anything on the uh the like energy
crisis stuff that's probably unfolding?
No, I I just I did just see Trump say they're going to escort
tankers through the Strait of Hormuz.
I mean,
okay, maybe maybe they're going to do that. So, the Strait of
Hormuz was closed, and basically
I watched this Peter Zeihan video, which is I I know some people
don't like Peter Zeihan, but I think he does a pretty good job
with like, if I want 5 minutes of somebody to just explain to
me like a couple of things that are important that are happening,
he's quite good at it. Um but basically, the funny thing I thought
about the Strait of Hormuz is basically
I think
is it Europe gets a whole bunch of its energy from one, like
the the Strait of Hormuz Strait of Hormuz a little bit, but also
the places Iran's attacking, like there's a gas field where they
get a ton of natural gas in Qatar,
and that gets sent I think it's like
the number I heard was like 10% of UK households get their gas
from this specific gas >> Yeah, I know energy prices are
just a
and so, the funny thing is is basically
people were really quickly hypothesizing like, oh, I think um
I I think
probably they're going to start talking to Russia again, cuz
what else are they going to do? They just going to like let energy
prices triple or something in their countries?
And literally last night, middle of the night, Ukraine goes in,
destroys a bunch of like oil equipment [laughter] at the biggest
at the biggest port in Russia, their biggest oil export >> I
have to respect that. I have to respect that so much, you know?
Well, it's like total By the way, they were told by the Americans,
"Please don't strike this port. Please don't hit this port. Leave
this port alone."
They're just like
>> You know what, actually?
cuz you know, they're they're basically just being asked to like
let themselves get right? Like if if if Russia does start selling
oil and gas back to Europe, they're a totally economically enabled,
they're going to roll over
So, it's like that they're looking at that they're like, "Well,
we're getting weapons from the US. We got Russia on the other
side." It's like, "You know, we know Russia has no empathy for
us, so we'll hope the US can forgive us for this one."
>> Dude, it's
Anyway, the whole thing is quite interesting. So, I've got this
video and then I've got a
Basically, this article was like groundbreaking yesterday or
this morning, and now it's like a little less groundbreaking
cuz basically everybody has realized that it's It's not that
the Strait of Hormuz is closed, it's insurance prices that's
keeping everybody out. But, pretty much everybody picked this
up almost instantly today. So, this isn't really even groundbreaking
anymore. We've covered it a little bit. And now also Trump might
escort people. I don't know that an escort
is going to matter a I do wonder how they're intercepting like
if if it's just Shahad's flying in, I do wonder what they're
going to do about that. Do you have Do you have like a lot of
thoughts on the Iran war overall? Like I've gotten I've not really
talked to too many people. >> Yeah, I think it's disgusting.
I think it's like totally
just like no one's even attempting to make an argument why it's
legal.
It's It's like transparent they were going to all do it and support
it. And then they're like, "Oh yeah, we need like a we need I
forgot we need to justify this in the government." It's not just
not just that It's not just that that It's like I think genuinely
like I look at I genuinely I'm like so enraged by Line of Action's
H3 appearance. I look at people that are doing this but it's
like "Oh yeah, well, I think it maybe be a good thing to do if
it wasn't like Trump doing it." I think you should be in prison.
I think you need to be like tried or something cuz you're scum.
Well, I mean, hold on. So, you might have a different if the
broad base of American people were moved by the plight of Iranians
genuinely such that they wanted to go and do this, I'm like,
okay, that's American leaders acting in their interest. You could
argue it's evil, maybe it would be evil. But like if they >> the
case. Go make the [__] case.
Yeah, they probably make that >> case to the UN and
security council. >> international Yeah, I think an international
coalition would be good, too. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But I'm like,
they're not even Like this This guy's America first. And it's
like, dude, all of the America first people basically the top
of their list was don't go to war with Iran. That was like number
one on everybody's list. We kind of just all assumed that was
going to be
And what do you think about the fact that basically these people
have taken
they had like their civil war, and I think they basically I think
they're like Israel first lobby basically lost that Republican
civil war, but they they just kind of shut up and they still
have probably a ton of boomers who don't really follow online
stuff. But now with this Iran
war, I feel like Tucker Carlson and Nick Fuentes are like elated
and just like feel proven right again.
Like that that coalition is only growing massively. Like I I
I think it's actually like going to be a threat in the midterms
now. When Fuentes says don't vote, like I told you war with Iran
was coming, they all said I was crazy. Don't vote for them. They're
them. We don't vote for them. I think that's actually a real
concern for them going into the midterms.
Yeah, I don't think it's obviously just Fuentes.
I get you, man. Yeah. Well, Carlson, too. Yeah, I think it's
like broadly a feeling people >> Yeah, yeah, it's it's
like that's what I mean, but it's like not even just about like
those immediate personalities. It's like, yeah, more broad. That
type of person just exists, if you know what I
Yeah, yeah, sure, sure, sure. It's like
There's just so much um Like even here, even in the UK, cuz like
Iraq and [__] it's pretty bad with um There's a lot
of people that just hate the idea of any action and kids taking
a lot of [__] right now for not being firm enough
on it.
Uh so I know that that type of exists in America, especially
like old old sort of libertarian Republican
Well, and it's like you could almost justify some of these things
when the American economy is booming. But like you're so far
away from that right now. It's like so off the pulse. Like the
last thing anyone wants to do is be spending money on
a war with Iran for the sake of Israel. Like like the fact that
it's and they did such a poor job of messaging, too. Like the
fact that there's no imminent threat. There's zero imminent threat.
Yeah. Right? Any imminent threat is created by the Israelis forcing
the issue. Yep. And so there's no imminent threat. There's no
reason to do this. You just decided to opt in.
Yeah, I think it's so tone-deaf.
I don't know. It's really I think it's >> there for the
midterms. I don't know what comes after that. Trump knows he's
>> And then literally Israel supporters Israel apologists
anti-Zionist narrative people just like they look like the biggest
marks alive right now. You know what I'm saying?
Israel is not at fault for the foreign policy of the US. What
are your strategic interests? Yeah. Yeah.
Nice one. Done. [__] idiot now.
Dude, I
I got linked to me even more disturbing [__] today.
This article is this Substack right here. Basically, um
apparently there's a like separation of What is this place called?
The Military Religious Freedom Foundation. So, apparently there's
like a place they run this foundation to take complaints on people
trying to force like religion into the armed forces in a way
that's inappropriate given the separation of church and state.
Apparently
tons of reports have been flooding in about basically like commanders
doing Christian Zionist propaganda.
Hold on. Let me get Let me get the quote. Um A combat unit commander
told non-commissioned officers at a briefing on Monday that the
Iran war is part of God's plan and that President Donald Trump
was anointed by Jesus to light the signal fire in Iran to cause
Armageddon and mark his return to Earth.
It's like
Oh, this is like a total mind virus and I I hate
I hate that I see it this way, but you just said the word. I
was like, we need a total de-Zionification of the evangelical
movement in the US. Like it actually needs to be treated like
I don't believe that's actually that influential. I don't think
that's actually that influential, to be honest.
You don't I I think people very sincerely believe it. There are
I think that's why he's >> sincerely believe it. I don't
I don't so crazy. You really? I don't think that's why he's quite
so crazy.
I think I think it's a huge >> Is that really Is that really
that common of a belief?
I think Charlie Kirk believed this. I think Charlie Kirk would
have been 100% behind this war for this exact reason.
I think it's why he was so incredibly >> must be like some
polling or some [__] How come there's no way this
belief is that common? I don't believe I think this belief is
way more like
Like more people believe this.
I would want to know what's the bigger block. All black people
in the US or people who believe exactly this thing? Uh black
people. I think that's close.
I thought it's going to be like 5 10%
It will go varying levels of sincerity, but the broad Christian
Zionist belief that like Israel has to be protected because it's
fundamental to like the end of humanity or whatever. I think
that's going to be up at like 15% I'm not joking. No shot.
Cuz that's What is it? 30 Is it 34%
of the US is evangelical, right? I think.
Uh hold on. Let me make sure I have my original cuz I'm presuming
34% of the US is evangelical. Christian national I'm not looking
for Christian nationalism. I don't think this is uh Christian
nationalism I want.
Christian Christian nationalism is different from Christian Zionism.
In my opinion. >> It's the It's the evangelical Zionism
thing, where it's like
the the specific narrative about how the third temple has to
be built, whatever the [__] you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's It's Christian
It's literally the name of it.
Uh exposes the return of the Jewish people to the Holy Land.
Likewise, it holds that the founding of Israel in 1948 was in
accordance with biblical prophecies transmitted through the Old
And like this stuff literally just
I feel like this stuff only started taking root in the US like
in the '70s,
That like wasn't that big a deal in the US, and then in the '70s
suddenly stuff starts stuff stuff starts popping off
Can honestly say the Marines I deployed with, virtually none
of them believed in this crap. I don't think it's the soldiers,
either. Like the thing about this article is it also points out
that like Trump's pastor believes this, and Hexit goes to Bible
study with Trump's
And it's like
And that's also very concerning.
Yeah, it's a I don't know. If I I feel like you need to investigate
this and find out how pervasive it is, especially in command.
Cuz it's like it's absolutely
>> I hate that There could be religious justifications
on both sides. Go ahead. >> Baseless not on the like the
lock them up train. I feel like basically every
It should be the the Democrat narrative in America basically
be, you know, illustrate every aspect of the Trump admin >> You
should be thankful that we're calling for investigations and
not [__] gallows. >> Basically. Yeah. Yeah.
Like it's Yeah.
I've been there for a while. I hear whenever I talk about um
Howard Lutnick, okay? When I watch him smile after he's like
photographed, he took his kids to Epstein Island, I watch him
into like walk into Congress for the State of Union. He's like
smiling and laughing with people. I'm like, "Dude, I I need to
violate TOS. I have a burning need to violate TOS right now."
Ah.
It's the worst. This guy's the >> thing. It's a second
thing. These people, am I right?
It's literally just It's like the people in charge right now,
Cozart. It's not It's not these people, not in the way you mean
it, okay? Nope. Nope.
Uh I think they announce the scheduled testimony soon. Yeah,
it won't matter. He'll just, you know, he'll basically refuse
to answer anything or say he doesn't remember.
Yeah, I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I Israel and like how it's the government's representative
of the people and all that [__] Just like reminded
me of like what the people say where it's like "Oh, you can't
talk [__] about the IDF because I they all have to
be in it. So, if you say death to the IDF, you're saying death
to all Israelis." and all these stupid arguments people make.
It's like yeah, it's like you Why Why do they get drafted? Like
even the Like when Cozart says, it's like even the opposition
party wants people drafted. It's not like it's No one likes the
draft. They get drafted cuz they vote. They get drafted cuz they
like it. Cuz they want to sit around like that.
It's like you just You just look. It's like since the Likud has
has been a thing, essentially since the Likud has been a thing,
they've had barely interrupted power. Like barely barely interrupted
power.
And for the past 30 years, they've had what? Two,
eight. So, 22 of the past 30 years, they've been in power.
It's like I I'm sorry. This is just what you want. This is like
straight up what you want.
You want what they want. Why are we pretending that we
dude, they don't represent us. They don't represent all all Israelis.
It's like, "Oh, you guys are getting by like a first past the
post voting system, right?" Nope. Purely proportional democracy,
purely proportional
As in like they're their votes go towards the government they
want, okay?
Hold on, what is this? What is this? What is this?
I don't remember. Yeah, he'll just say I don't remember. Yeah.
Bro, they were straight chilling.
I don't know how you take your kids with you. That's the weird
thing to me. Like isn't this the island? Why are you taking your
kids to a island trip?
What's wrong with you, man? Jesus.
What are we looking for here? Can't think of anything else. I've
been caught up with you in a couple days. Oh, did you watch any
of the Aaron Hutch stuff?
I was in the Yeah, I saw some of the Lycan thing. I heard it
mentioned there, but I haven't seen it.
Uh maybe you'll check it out. It's just like um I think basically
from what I understand Straight Rid was supposed to go on and
talk about like how Hutch handled that. Did you watch Livin'
Learn with the Shot Guy at all? You see any of that? >> Some
of it. I saw bits.
It was basically she was going on to argue about that or something,
and then Hutch just basically was like, "Let's talk about communism.
How are you going to implement real communism now?" Right. And
the whole conversation is about
I I tweeted about it online. This is unironically like what the
conversation was. Was Straight Rid was basically saying like
my first principle is I don't want to overthrow democracy and
like act against people's will. Which by the way is like Hutch's
main problem with MLs and communists, right? That you don't respect
liberal democracy. And then it was like, "Okay, how do you even
buy a TV with
It's rough. Rough stuff, man.
Side note, I still don't understand how you talk about abolishing
money in anywhere where you can't just like auto-generate anything
you want.
Otherwise, you need money. You have like pure control over physics
and you can like materialize any of your desires instantly, then
like maybe you don't need money, but otherwise you need some
exchange, some way of exchanging things.
I know that's what communism's end goal is, but it's like
to get there you need otherwise there's a people can exploit
the system, right?
So you need the materializer, you need to like yeah, the replicator
from Star Trek or whatever.
What about Anarcho-Syndicalists spiral downwards into anti-semitism?
Are you following any of that?
No, not actively.
You saw the good tweet? Waking up? Yeah, I saw that one.
She was on um Jon Pierres talking about how Trump's gotten on
his knees to suck off Israel.
Um committing That's what I was referring to. How many of us
like
courageous in that he didn't get on his knees to suck off Israel.
Uh I wouldn't say I don't necessarily agree with that. I think
uh it's awesome
go down with the ship, you got to respect that.
You don't You don't agree that he didn't get down on his knees
to suck off Israel? Is that what you're saying? Well, I just
don't think that, you know, it's necessary with the thing of
courage when you suck off Israel. Trump's not
going on with Israel cuz he's a coward, he's going on with Israel
cuz he's self-interested in that, you know, they're lining his
and Kushner's
Okay, that's basically my thought as well. That's why um Like
that's That's why I I think he would even be a little more conflicted
if Iran was like if Saudi Arabia were wanted any sort of anything
to do with Iran. Like like if they didn't basically want them
destroyed. Yeah, like they are a big part as well. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, 100%. Yeah, I agree. And so it's
like all of the all of the people who pay him all want the same
thing done, so he's just like, well, I guess I'll do it. Yeah,
Which is another reason that you need to investigate all these
people cuz that's all they're doing. They're just selling your
country out.
You Why is it explain this to me? Explain this to me, Jace. Explain
this to me. Charlie Kirk said Joe Biden should be tried and given
the electric chair.
But I would be banned from platforms. Um yeah, I think that would
be the case.
How do I explain it? Unfortunately, I think it even gets we can't
even Zog posted this one. I would love to tell you that it's
like the running stuff. I actually think it's straight up that
Trump openly threatens anybody who talks about him like threatens
>> Yeah, it's like every American company is basically
like quivering in fear right right now basically. That's the
issue fundamentally is like basically every private private and
public institution frankly in America is like quivering in fear
and desperately trying not to Yeah. attract his attention. >> Like
you know me, I would love to have blamed the Trump for this one,
but it just seems genuinely like he is a like an actual fascist
in this case who's threatening all of these companies. So like
stand up against me and see what
We're going to go after you. And yeah, it's every company explicitly
is like scared. Yeah. >> Yeah, yeah.
Very unfortunate.
Honestly wonder why I see like the most dog [__]
like mega stuff getting loads of views. Honestly wonder how like
how much the scale is like tipped and [__] now. I
don't know how much it's tipped or like if
it's hard for me to say cuz like there is some element of >> some
inherent popularity towards the most like just degenerate like
racist like Well, and just the lying popular stuff. Like it's
literally just you lying to tell people what they want to hear.
So it will get views in some way. There's like some of that as
well. And basically they're trying to get rid of like all the
overt lying just for views.
Like overt and harmful lying I guess like stuff about COVID and
[__] And now that that's gone, you just do this as
much as you want. I think there's some element of people opting
into it.
I I think you used to be able to do these kinds of investigations
on Twitter. I think it's getting a lot harder now. They've closed
off all of their APIs. It's all super expensive to go and look
at any of it, so
I don't even know how you really get numbers on this stuff anymore
to be honest with you. It's Yeah, I don't know. I don't know
how you stop the botting, the human manipulation. It should be
Why can people pretty much say what they like about Muslims,
but uh I could now be charged for an opinion against Israel.
You could be charged? I mean, I can I feel like I can speak against
Israel all I want.
I feel like I feel like the problem with Twitter specifically
has been and Elon Musk kind of stood on this a little bit, so
you you give him the tiniest amount of credit, that basically
they're like, you have to stop He was like, I'm going to let
everything go. And they're like, you have to stop people from
being racist and then he was like, No.
And then he lost all of his advertisers immediately. And then
he immediately lost all of his advertisers, so Uh
new anti-Semitism laws? Where? Where are the new anti-Semitism
laws? Yeah, this rage bait, too, could be a part of
Man, I I This truly is Like, there is a the Hasan is bad thing
is like a subset of the broader like um rage baiting issue. Like,
you using how bad somebody how somebody or something else is
to get people to like look away from what they should be looking
at. And so, it's a little funny. I think this is like the ultimate
This is like the apex of that. Like, can I convince you to send
your kids to die for Israel if it's to own the libs? Can I interest
you in dying for Israel to own the libs? Can I Hey, fight a war
for Israel to own the >> walk. That's just my walk.
>> It's It's Oh, man.
Newsom likens Israel to apartheid state, questions future military
support. Newsom's killing it. Newsom's killing it. This is Well,
this is how you can tell like >> has figured it out, man.
I'm I'm telling you, this guy is like
I already said like I I was of the opinion and everybody doubted
me and I gave my reasoning for it when it happened. It was unironically
the clavicular reason. Clavicular just like stole my rationale
for it. I was like, "Hey, he's like a hot white guy and you get
all of the white vote and you get some of the woman vote if you
just run him with whatever poli- It doesn't even matter what
the platform is. Run him as a Democrat as like a an attractive
white dude with a white family. You get the entirety of the white
vote in the Midwest. You get like all of the other shit." Right?
It's It's so simple. So, I think anything he does on top of that
to just tap into populism, he's going to be running up numbers
like hardcore. J.D. Vance isn't going to be the candidate. J.D.
Vance forfeited his his candidacy with this um with this
In my opinion, I think it's over for
I think a huge part of J.D.'s whole coalition
was Tucker and Tucker can no longer reconcile with J.D.
And not not without looking like massive frauds and getting it
pointed out to
Like I think I think it's over for for J.D. in any real sense.
Um Cozza asked if I saw that Dan Crenshaw thing. I've already
watched one Dan Crenshaw clip tonight. >> Dan Crenshaw
tweet that AF post put out is so stupid. Cozza's trying to get
you to look at this stupid tweet with like thumbs in it.
This is the only one I want. I'm Dan
Can you please respect Israel?
That's the only one I want. >> the the tweet the tweet
is like uh it's
Representative Dan Crenshaw has just lost a primary race. Uh
he's been blindsided by a primary loss uh after being eyed for
replacement by his uh
opponent of whatever his name is. Uh The constituents say he
lost sight of their interests.
Uh-huh. Terrible. Absolutely terrible. You can pull that up.
You have to play the Hasan Dan Crenshaw clip. What's the Hasan
Dan Crenshaw clip?
What is this?
Uh that Dan Crenshaw Oh, the brave brave
[__] his eye. [__] his eye hole. Classic,
man.
A tier, okay. This guy
Uh no shot.
>> What happened to his eye? I could tell where it was
going almost instantly.
That's funny. I'm sorry, that's very funny. Hassan, you don't
want to say what happened to his eye or What?
>> That's like an intentional
You're probably wondering how we got
But let me tell you. I'll just include it. Maybe?
Thank you. Thank you, Tequila Sunset. Geez, I just want to watch
him talk about this guy's eye hole getting [__] man.
How Is that too much to ask? Soft power is the exact same as
hard power. Soft power, embassies, diplomacy,
exact same thing as military bases. I'm I can't do this. I can't
do it. This guy has the understanding of foreign policy uh of
like a 12-year-old.
What the [__] What the [__] is wrong
with this dude? Didn't he go to war and like literally lose his
eye because some Mujahideen, a brave soldier, [__]
his eye hole with their dick? Isn't that how he lost his dumbass
eye? Cuz he got his eye hole [__] by a brave soldier.
Didn't he learn that there's a difference between like military
bases and and diplomacy? The voice trading is crazy, isn't it?
It really is. It's a big difference there.
Guys, it's the Yeti. Guys, it's the There There are people in
my chat who are such unironic like massive Hassan simps. They
will actually do the It was just a Yeti, guys. It's just It was
just blue Yeti, okay? It couldn't detect the looseness voice.
That's all. Guys, it was It was the blue Yeti. It was the blue
Yeti.
Where's Where's your zortician at? Cuz now I actually want to
watch this. Look for something neither Kwebbelkop or I have seen.
Somebody was linking me this. could be the entire thing. Even
if Iran
Hold on, this is
Jeremy Scahill. Apparently, this was somebody who's a part of
the negotiations or has some idea of the negotiations with Iran.
Apparently, this is good.
Almost as crazy as Jay Stalk's old voice. What's my old voice?
My old voice is exactly the same. I just sound way less
Just like monotone?
thing. Even if Iran had capitulated in you know, shocking way,
that they still would have gone short of the Iranians declaring
that they that they're no longer going to be in Iran anymore
and that Trump is welcome to take over or Pahlavi can come and
walk right in and we'll hand him the keys to the to the shop.
But, you had all of this stuff going on and the Iranians, we
started talking to see
are you aware that like the Iranian Kurds are like the lowest
group in terms of favorability towards Pahlavi?
Um, no, I'm not aware of that.
That is the case. They hate Pahlavi. And I just think it's funny
that a lot of people are like, "Okay, they're finally going to
do it." >> they the only ones with guns other than the
IRGC? >> They are and well they are and they're also getting
the Iraqi Kurds who are going to come in with more guns provided
by the CIA.
>> Unironically being reported by multiple places. So
So we're getting Kurdistan? So we're getting Kurdistan finally?
The you know you know what they say third time's the charm. >> You
know what they say, third third time's the charm. Third time's
the charm, okay? Yeah, yeah, they got it. They got it this time.
Surely America won't yank the football like Lucy and their Charlie
Brown, okay? Surely won't happen again. You guys get Kurdistan
this time, I promise. Oh, actually we have something better.
Never mind. Bye, Kurds.
in your Iranian officials and what they said is, "We're putting
on the table things that go far beyond the
All right.
Jeremy Scales in the building. Jeremy Scales of dropsite
is in the building. It's Jeremy I expect these people to be armed
and empowered to grab their freedom, okay? Everybody but the
Persians who are in all the major cities, they're all going to
get guns and get told to seize their freedom, okay? And somehow
this will lead to a better situation than the IRGC. Not totally
sure yet, but it it's apparently going to happen. He's on the
first flight back to Toronto he's on the first flight back to
go and help build the new society, right?
You cannot fly in there, okay? No, that's not happening. >> Welcome
back.
I I did say oh, I did say though that the person on the
I had that same recommendation for the person on the Piers panel
from before. They're like a Canadian citizen. She's got like
a a bigger got a big Israel flag, a big America flag, big Iran
flag in the room. No Canadian flag shockingly somehow.
Literally used to be in the the provincial parliament, the provincial
legislature for Ontario. No Canadian >> Jeremy, unfortunately
every single time we have you on, it always feels like the world
is collapsing. Wait, Scales an incre- Scales an incredibly biased
reporter though. He's literally quoted Zizek as a source.
Wait, a source for what?
It would be important. Like if the Zizek if the if the Zizek
person was a source for like what somebody was saying on
right? If they're a source that that is a source. If they're
a source for like what the American foreign policy is in some
region or something, then obviously that's insane.
You You just gave me some information that sounds really really
really like
but I would need to know what the Zizek person was sourced for,
happening right in front of our eyes, but it's still an honor
to have you on
Can you hear me? Thank you for having Yeah, thank you for having
me back. Of course. Uh So, you guys you just got done with your
reporting. I believe you're in come officials on the Iranian
and and drops I just revealed
a couple hours ago or or your your latest reporting shows you
know, a very different perspective than what we're seeing in
mainstream media, but I know you're paying close attention to
what's going on in the news. Oh, by the way, I do have to say
Kyle Kulinski is not doing himself favors right now. Have you
seen any of his posts on this? No.
Yeah, I believe he's unironically being Iran Iran is totally
winning this military engagement right now. I feel like I'm not
I'm not really getting too far off a base for what his like actual
opinions have been.
I got to go find that post. >> the energy. I appreciate
the energy.
It It's been pretty insane cope from him over a couple different
things.
The energy, maybe.
I If he's anti-Israel, it's fine, but it hurts when he's just
saying totally insane things.
Well, I mean, hurts his reputation, makes me laugh, so I don't
know. Maybe doesn't hurt that bad. Who's Let's get started with,
you know, the the
I guess now almost 50-year project of Israel finally
finally coming to a close.
Do you feel like there is any Do you feel like there there's
any argument that you have heard so far that made you go, "Hmm,
maybe this is a real reason for what Sorry. Hold on. Send Baron.
Sorry, that's funny. Baron Baron is like 9 ft tall. Baron is
like the first attempt at genetic engineering for significant
attempt, okay?
This guy's like looking [laughter] up.
All right, we're going with Iran. No, and I I think it has to
be stated at the beginning, you know, just from a an American
perspective that you know, the Democrats as it we we've seen
this coming for weeks and weeks that that Trump was going to
move forward on this and you know, at at dropsite we've been
reporting on on things that we've heard even from people within
the inner circle. One of the things we reported recently is that
Trump has been kind of stomping around even in internal briefings
making statements like I'm going to go down as the president
that forever changed the Iranian regime and and obsessively talking
about the 79 revolution and the seizure of the you know, of the
embassy and they they've been you know, this whole thing started
on its surface in you know, mid-January after the protests
in Iran that then converted into very
battles and attacks in the streets of Tehran and other cities
around Iran and there's competing narratives about what happened
there. But Trump seized on that moment in Iran and said help
is on the way. And of course, you know, the utterly discredited
son of the deposed Shah also was calling on Iranians to rise
up and seize institutions and then nothing happened in the immediate
aftermath of that and then Trump basically
almost entirely stopped talking about Iran is brutal to its own
citizens and they're murdering their own citizens. You know,
he was obsessively claiming that he had stopped all of these
public hangings
but you know, they basically
I mean from what I've seen it was actually lined up to when the
Shah said go. Now, whether that was because of the Shah or not,
I don't know. But it was it was lined up with when the Shah said
go, wasn't it? When the actual like height of the protest was?
I don't know how to differentiate I guess. I didn't follow closely
enough. My one maybe you have a good idea.
Oh, Trump did take credit for this though. Yeah, that he got
the the what do you call it? The protest to
like the protesters to be set free or
It started before? Oh, he said go after it had already started
raging. Uh that's not great. That's not That's not great. Not
great. Not great. >> dispense with that and then they resume
this talk about nuclear weapons. And you know, every US national
intelligence estimate going back years um had concluded that
for the end of 2003, Iran had given up its nuclear weapons uh
ambitions. And then in you know, in June uh Trump conducted all
of these strikes over 12 days on the three main nuclear sites
in Iran. And then they they said that they had completely and
totally obliterated Iran's nuclear
Yeah, I don't know why nuclear
I don't know. Yeah, I have no idea. >> a special web page
on the White House website to de- preemptively declare as fake
news anyone that would dare to say you know, otherwise. And then
last weekend, we had Steve Whitkoff,
Trump's special envoy. He and Jared Kushner, the president's
son-in-law, are the point guys on all of this. Um Whitkoff makes
like a Cheney-style statement and says, "Iran is a week away
from having industrial-grade
bomb-making material."
Uh and they provided no evidence for that whatsoever, but it
also sort of was like, "Well, wait a minute. You either totally
obliterated the program or it's gotten so advanced that they're
a week away from it." So, they start obsessing about this and
they're supposedly in By the way, these people like these people
are so egotistical. Like Trump's so egotistical.
That they can't even admit they like even if they hadn't destroyed
it or something and that's like that people would at least be
able to buy that cope, but they refuse to admit that they didn't
completely wipe out their nuclear capacity the first time in
the in Midnight Hammer. Like they will continue to harp about,
"No, we totally destroyed it. We obliterated it other utterly.
It's utterly destroyed." Like okay, but then how did they But
then how did they have that No, no, no, they rebuilt it. Think
What?
It's It's like you could just give up the first claim, but Trump
can't give anything up to like even look a little bit credible
to his own people. negotiations again. Just what happened last
year in June happened now, which is that they claimed they were
going to have another round of technical talks in Vienna, Austria
on Monday. The Omani foreign minister last night was with Vice
President J.D. Vance and said that the prospects for a deal are
very serious. And then, you know, people wake up this morning
to uh news that the United States and Israel have launched massive
bombing at sites and cities across Iran. Um the death toll in
this strike that hit the uh girl's school in Iran is has now
officially surpassed 85. I'm hearing from sources in Iran that
there's been a strike on a some kind of a um a gym facility in
another area of Iran. Wait, did that say 85 for the school? Oh,
80 Oh, oh. Oh, oh.
Yeah, that's what happens. Oh.
I believe it's more than doubled now, right? So, like 170?
175 I thought I'd heard. I thought I'd heard 175. Maybe that
was Anna who said that.
No, maybe it's less. Maybe it's less. >> on a some kind
of a um a gym facility in another area of Iran uh where children
have also been killed. Um the Iranians, unlike last time uh the
that Israel and the US bombed, didn't wait to sort of absorb
it and then come up with their own calibrated response. You know,
as we've talked about before,
the Iranians have choreographed their retaliatory strikes through
back channels with the US in previous times. We've been reporting
for weeks they're not going to do that again. Yeah. Um in fact,
we've had sources close to the you know, power structure in Iran
that have said that they they understand that they're aiming
to kill at least 500 American personnel in retaliatory strikes.
So, delegation to launch strikes was dropped down to a much lower
command level in Iran, and that's why you saw an unprecedented
simultaneous retaliatory response from Iran across all of these
Gulf Arab countries. They also hit Jordan.
Bro, 500. They they plan to kill 500
Yeah, six.
It's um
That's kind of unfortunate, man. >> A colleague of mine
in Israel who's in a Well, sorry. It's unfortunate for them.
I of course I I'm not saying it's unfortunate in a general sense.
I'm just saying it's unfortunate for them. They were going to
go for 500. They've got six so far. >> shelter right now
just sent me a message >> away. saying that the pattern
of these strikes is unlike anything we've seen in its previous
attacks and that the the public instructions are to stay inside
of those shelters much longer
a much longer duration than ever before
you know, during these retaliatory strikes from Iran. Iranian
naval vessels from the IRGC have been turning ships away at the
Strait of Hormuz. It's unclear if it's officially closed right
now, but it appears that could well happen. But, you know, to
put it to put a fine point on it, let's remember that the Democrats
have seen this coming.
I at the risk of making this change, okay? At the risk of getting
this to
I just have to highlight, okay, really
that in this in this thing where where Tysca came back and said
Shah Reza Pahlavi is the person who's the the plan, okay? That
after 9 hours, that tweet despite 500 views still at zero likes.
Literally zero likes on that tweet. Okay?
Literally literally zero. Even though I showed it on stream already.
I've already shown it on stream once. It's still at literally
zero likes. Now, I know that me pointing this out and highlighting
it will cause it to get likes. But, I still think it's [__]
hilarious that after 9 hours that >> More evidence you
need to be mentally disabled to think this. Even though even
though Pisco has 1,500 views on his response, okay? So, there's
like literally nobody between these two tweets. 5,000, 1,500.
Literally nobody viewing both of these tweets felt like they
could go and like the Shah Reza Pahlavi tweet, okay?
I should I'm just saying.
>> I should It's like so
man, you seriously should be so ashamed of saying that [__]
So [__] dumb. I How do you I would be curious cuz
cuz basically the reason I don't think the MEK will be installed
is probably the same reason I don't think the Shah could be installed
cuz I don't think they're going to Well, I didn't for a long
time. I guess it boots up I This all absent boot up >> I
don't think it will happen. Oh, you said schizo >> I'm
I'm saying it's a schizo sort of like, you know, this is the
off chance something happens. But, if it were to happen, it would
happen because the US went in with boots on the ground probably
with other Gulf states.
you know, in some kind of coordinated effort to install a new
regime. Uh and I I think that in that case that they do that,
they would choose the MEK over Reza Pahlavi. That's basically
what I'm saying. I'm not saying like this is what I think is
going to happen. I'm saying should the US decide they're going
to actual regime change and go in and actually do it, it will
be the MEK, not Reza Pahlavi.
it's interesting cuz in terms of that like double schizo thing
that like if they were to do that, I think that would be my second
indication. I think
I think Syria didn't go the way Israel wanted it to go. I think
they probably wanted somebody who was sympathetic to them getting
installed and it ended up being Turkey. I think you know, pray
pray there's a deep state of some kind that it's willing to work
against Israel's ambitions in some way and that they might be
wanting to like not give Israel everything they want. I think
Reza Pahlavi is obviously like Israel's creature, like pretty
clearly. Yeah. So, that would be interesting to me that like
this is why some people would be pushing against the idea and
not wanting him to be installed directly.
Yeah, I would have to I want to know more about what Pompeo's
thinking on it was or why they why he's been called. Cuz I I
know I read this uh Guardian
I listened to it. This Guardian article about the MEK and their
history and basically they they
There's this whole weird period in like the 2010s where they
are super close with Republicans and conservatives in the UK.
And like parliamentary uh uh parliamentary conservatives
are like shilling them in like the 2010s even though they're
like a cult.
They're I thought they were communists. Are they not communists?
>> a cult now.
They're like TLDR is like they were student communist group
that was like Islamo-communist or whatever, you know, reinterpret
the Quran through a communist lens and said
uh you know, Muhammad was a communist and wanted a classless
society. And so, they tried to rise up. So, they did that as
part of like the Soviet revolution whatever. And they get totally
And uh >> Wait, is this what people mean when they say
Islamo-communists?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And they they get totally
uh after the revolution by the Islamists and they get they sign
up with the rock for a bit and then they got got sent back into
a trap and get slaughtered. Um And then and then they become
like this compound
of like a few thousand people basically where all the women are
forced to divorce their husbands and marry the leader. And uh
yeah, it's like a whole thing. Like it's like that for ages.
They think it still be like that.
Rediscovering Mormonism from first principles, you love to see
it.
You love to see it. Very cool. All
I might have to look into it at some point. Holy [__]
There's a lot of stuff. I find Middle Eastern politics like super
interesting. Like whenever I do go down a rabbit hole on it,
it is very interesting.
The way things play out there, so
I might actually do that. Usually when I say I should look into
it, I don't. But yesterday I like got off stream and I just watched
like videos and and read stuff for like a couple hours before
I went to sleep.
Yeah, that's what I've been doing the past past few nights is
just listening to stuff about Iran.
Yeah, I just tapped in on this stuff. It's uh it's all very interesting.
Right after reading Rawls? No, I mean this like when I when the
Rawls thing came up, I was like no, I don't give a [__]
I I and I'm sorry, I just don't I've never committed to doing
that. But I'm actually doing this [__] cuz I want
Into some of the Middle Eastern politics stuff, so And Hakeem
Jeffries and Democratic leaders in the Senate as well refused
to bring to a vote this powers resolution. Now, I don't have
any illusions about the position of the Democrats. In fact, we
reported at Drop Site that Chuck Schumer and others are are cynically
hoping that Trump does exactly what he's doing right now for
two reasons. One, they actually support it. That's the most important
thing to understand. It's a bipartisan consensus. They support
it. They may not want to say it out loud. But then the other
component is that they cynically believe that if it goes foul
and wrong, remember 70% of Americans don't want this or that
it's going to be beyond Trump and it's going to help their electoral
chances. That's that's that's what you can distill this down
to. >> pull, man. This is making me realize like immediately.
It's like yeah, it's bipartisan except, you know, one of the
main potential
presidential candidates for the
Yeah, I think it's it's basically betting that that coalition
is bigger. And I do think
Well, the thing is is that the reason you want a paradigm shift
right now is because basically there's going to be like a big
group of people who are going to be thinking after this,
running within your party's platform basically ensures that you'll
never get more than like very marginal gains from the middle,
right? So, you try to do something different. This is like an
actual shift that could get big groups of Republicans to move
over. It's like the Trump's shift with MAGA that got a lot of
people to go over into um >> Yeah, things are kind of primed
right now for like the Fuentes coalition's kind of sliding behind
Newsom. The way like he's talking,
you know, I there's a whole clip of
I'll never vote for this, you know, I'll vote for Democrats.
>> I [laughter] said after I watched this stuff, I'm like,
they better thank their lucky stars that this guy wasn't born
like 7 years sooner or something. Okay? He's he's ineligible
to run. I I understand it's like a total pipe dream. I think
he's got like >> I don't think even if he was old enough,
I don't even think he was old enough. >> He's got the pulse
in a way that like nobody else does. Like he >> Yeah, but
people like that guys like that, like he is he does totally get
it, but that's why he's media. That's why he's not a politician.
>> Yeah, he's Well, he's I think he's totally erratic.
Like he he doesn't have the poise, right? Like he he'll just
Dude, somebody would pick him off and he'll like but I just watched
him talk about the Kurds earlier. He called the Kurds Kurds like
brutal savages or something, right? Somebody will like pick him
off and he'll like literally just like he would yeah, he would
be in a debate, he called somebody like a hard R or something.
Like it would just happen. He'd just get picked he'd like lose
it and he'd like hard R in the middle of a political debate and
it would just never work. >> quietly want Orange Hitler
to wage war that they also want, and then they hope it kind of
goes bad when he does it, even though they really want it to
succeed, but they kind of hope it goes bad in the eyes of the
American people, so that it helps them. It's a it's a win-win
and it's it it it captures in a nutshell the state of the institutional
Democratic Party's posture when it comes to foreign policy.
Yeah, absolutely. Uh I have the the Ryan Grim Ryan Grim tweet
here. It says, "Jeffries, who held off a powers resolution long
enough for Trump to go start the before it came to a vote, does
not condemn Trump's attack in his initial response. The party
leadership, as we reported last week, is eager to see Trump launch
this war." I'm I'm sure you've seen the House Minority Leader's
statement
on on this supposedly unprecedented surprise attack that America
and Israel conducted on Iran that they were signaling that they
were going to do as they launched an armada 50% more than 50%
of our entire naval assets were moved into the region over the
last month or so, and Donald Trump kept saying, just like he
did in the build-up to the 12-day war, that there was going to
be a negotiations process, but it was very clear. It was so clear
that I actually interviewed Ben Rhodes, a former Obama administration
national security advisor Ben Rhodes, about how these negotiations
were simply a sham. Israel had kept adding on additional qualifiers
to the negotiations,
many red lines that they were simply designing so that
so that, you know, the Iranians would inevitably say no. What
happened yesterday, however, was really interesting. The Omani
official that went on television, I think, knew that this was
probably going to happen, and that's precisely the reason why
they were saying, "No, no, no, Iran is actually totally on board
with the negotiations and even leaning into maximalist demands
that the American government was making on demands that were
even more
demands that were even more aggressive than the JCPOA as far
as like, you know, taking out enriched uranium from the country
and whatnot. And and I think they did that, this is speculation,
of course, but I think they did that just to show the American
population that uh the the Iranian side was absolutely
That unfortunately is never going to fly with the American but
like literally it's not because of anything to do with Oman.
It's literally like those are
You believe Arabs? You believe It's like so easy to discredit
anything coming out of those places, right?
be playing ball no matter how Like I I just don't think people
are going to believe this. I didn't see this part in the
Your Times article either. If this had secondary sourcing from
somewhere else, I could believe it but it does The statements
from the Omanis and this article seem to go against each other
a little bit. This says that they were that Tehran was was still
fairly belligerent when it came to negotiating the like spin
down of their nuclear
So as long as that's in here there's like some sort of reporting
that kind of conflicts, I think it'd be hard for a lot of Americans
to just go with the Omanis' word on it. Even if that might be
more trustworthy. >> ridiculous these negotiations were.
Yeah, you know, I mean also just to back up a bit, a couple of
weeks ago we started reporting based on sources that are informal
advisers to the Trump administration and are very well connected
with Arab governments. Um you know, that the that the US was
almost certainly going to move with an attack and that they needed
to The concern was not so much the offensive weaponry that the
US needed to get in place. They wanted to delay uh to bring in
refueling aircraft
um to bring in missile systems, THAAD and others that would be
capable of defending Israel or um you know, the American military
bases in the region. And you know, the the I I I I think there's
a real question of whether there was ever even a scintilla of
intent to negotiate in good faith. It could be that the entire
thing even if Iran had capitulated in an un you know, a shocking
way that What was the picture there?
Am I uh mis- misinterpreting something or was the negotiation
they were doing not basically just trying to get the Obama nuclear
deal back anyway?
Um well, I think they No, they wanted They wanted it like objectively
better.
Oh, really? The Omanis are saying that Iran was was capitulating
in in so far as they were giving away more aggressive timelines
in the JCPOA.
They were doing something like the JCPOA, but it was like even
more even more given away on the Iranian
Cuz they wanted to avoid the war. And it seems like that wasn't
good enough. But then the New York Times article says Hold on,
let me see if I can find the the part about that.
So, let's see here. As the administration was worried. I think
it's up here, is it not?
By then, Wycoff and Jared Kushner, the president's son-in-law,
were having indirect nuclear talks with the Iranians under orders
from Trump.
Uh let's see. Telling moment came when Mr. Wycoff spoke to Fox
News in an interview on February 21st and described Trump's reaction
to the Iranian reluctance to agree to zero enrichment, that is,
to dismantle its ability to produce nuclear fuel.
Even though the talks were about dismantling Iran's nuclear program,
the goal could be removing Iran's leadership. Sorry, it's
Uh this isn't This isn't an Oh, so they they want them to not
even be able to have like
any nuclear enrichment?
Yeah, no nuclear enrichment whatsoever. And they said we'll literally
provide you the fuel. No, they said we'll provide fuel for your
power stations. Like you don't need any of the tools to enrich.
We'll give you the fuel for your power stations.
So, so like that sounds like
I I think probably there's some diplomacy thing going on here.
We're in the back of everyone's head, it's like you have to give
us some way because otherwise we will like have otherwise you
could just come cuz every other part of this is basically like
we could come in like totally whenever you want. Right? It's
like giving up your sovereignty as a country.
So, I think they they want like some sort of understanding that
we're going to make like small pursuits, but we're not going
to go and if we get close, you can come back, but I think there's
something like that going on there kind of.
Right? Where it's like they're they're not going to give up the
ability to enrich nuclear weapons, which they they probably didn't
under the or nuclear grade weapon grade nuclear material, but
I'm guessing they probably kept enrichment enrichment capabilities
under the JCPOA, I'm guessing.
Like as a way to be like, "Hey, well, if we're ever like feeling
that you guys aren't letting off of sanctions or something weird
is happening, we want the equipment there to start spinning up
But I don't know. The enrichment. I I feel like this article
is basically telling me that
Iran was refusing.
Rubin and Ratcliffe talked about the intelligence behind the
strikes, possible timing, and potential off-ramp if the Iranians
were willing to give up nuclear enrichment at upcoming talks.
Iranians presented the Americans with a seven-page plan with
proposed levels of future nuclear enrichment, numbers that alarmed
Mr. Wekauf and Mr. Kushner. The Americans still wanted the Iranians
to commit to zero enrichment and proposed giving them free nuclear
fuel for a civil nuclear program, but the Iranians refused, a
US official said. So, this right here to me does not So, I I
hear from the Iranian side that they were ready to basically
totally capitulate on the nuclear front. And then from this article,
which does seem to have like basically has been confirmed in
some other places, it seems like that's not the case.
Uh one last chance to give up their nuclear enrichment ambitions,
then pushed up till Friday, and then I
I think that's the last thing. So, basically, yeah, they never
they basically never give it up.
Is my understanding.
Uh there's speculation the US didn't the US side didn't understand
what they were asking for and didn't understand what the Iranians
were asking for. Okay, Iran probably wanted at least some token
thing. Well, I think they I I also don't think, and I don't know
if they ever discussed it. I don't hear discussions in here about
them giving up their ballistic weapons, their ballistic missile
program.
So, that seems to have been included now after the fact that
like, "Hey, you can't have the capacity to ever target Israel
again with these ballistic
And I don't think that was ever a part of their actual negotiations
here.
Kind of interesting.
thing. Even if Iran had capitulated in an un you know, a shocking
way, that they still would have gone short of the Iranians declaring
that they that they're no longer going to be in Iran anymore,
and that Trump is welcome to take over, or Pahlavi can come and
walk right in, and we'll hand him the keys to the to the shop.
But, Oh, this is also true, that basically they do the same thing
they do with Hamas with Iran, that as long as your as long as
your like rallying cry is "Death to America, death to Israel",
you'll always pursue weapons, you'll always pursue nukes, you'll
always So, like to them, regime change, like disarming them in
a nuclear sense, yeah, it means regime change, like it's the
same one in the same. >> But, you had all of this stuff
going on, and the Iranians, we started talking to senior Iranian
officials, and what they said is, "We're putting on the table
things that go far beyond the scope of the JCPOA 2015 agreement."
In fact, one official said to me, "You know, it would shock John
Kerry." And John Kerry, of course, was the Secretary of State
uh and and was the So, this guy is also saying we're going beyond
in some ways beyond the JCPOA.
>> In fact, one official said to me, "You know, it would
shock John Kerry." >> And John Kerry, of course, was the
Secretary of State uh and and was the lead negotiator of the
deal. And and and so, the enrichment levels, um the oversight
mechanisms they were willing to talk about, uh the idea that
they would then have negotiations down the line, that they were
going to buy American civilian aircraft, that they were going
to open Iran's doors again to investment opportunities for American
oil and gas companies and potentially other American corporations.
They put all of this on the table and I think that from their
perspective, they weren't uh Pollyannaish about what they were
facing. They know that Trump is kind of
you know, a crooked godfather.
>> They know that Trump is Israel's golem, okay? The strongest
golem. >> As head of state, uh you know, running around
with his consigliere, Jared Kushner, and and you know, Steve
Witkoff that Oh. Wait. Oh, I see what he's
They made a personal offer, too, right?
They weren't shy about that. Made a personal offer, as well.
Listen, we're going to open ourselves up to investment, wink
wink. Like, possibly, you know, Kushner first investment, wink
wink. Witkoff first investment, wink wink. That real estate mogul
who's running around doing all of the bidding for Trump, but
they felt like, "We're going to show the world that we are exercising
maximum flexibility on this question." And for some moments,
it did seem And by the way, I I I was told that there were actual
direct talks between the US and the Iranians, not just in this
last round, but going back to February 6th in Oman. And the Iranians
were saying that they had a sense that the Americans were Am
I the only person this seems to have been totally desynced for
me? Let me try to restart it. See if that fixes it. Americans
were even taken aback by some of what they were willing to put
on the table. So, I you know, and I talked to Rob Malley, who
was on that negotiating I think that's the whatever program Hassan
and this guy are using, I think that's what's desynced. I don't
think Hassan's desynced. >> team in 2015, an American official,
former uh envoy to Iran under President Biden. And he said, "Trump
could just call it a day and declare victory on this. He He He's
He's he's like knocking it out of the park compared to Obama
in terms of what he's able to get out of the Iranians right now.
If the issue is they've got a victory here. But the thing is
the issue wasn't the issue hasn't ever been the issue is regime
change. The issue is fighting Israel's for it. You know, and
this all comes days after Mike Huckabee. I know you
Guys like lighting up right now. >> the stream, but days
after Mike Huckabee says to Tucker Carlson, "Perfectly acceptable
goal for Israel to try to move not just from the the sea, you
know, to the river, but from the sea to the Tigris and Euphrates."
Yeah.
Yeah, I know. This is It's Dude,
do you know who John Kun Rikus is? Uh IDF spokesperson.
You'd recognize him if you saw him.
Could I have a clean walk away? Okay, it's fine. What we're seeing
here is a combination of fact I said no. Oh. Oh. No, okay. Um
you you I think you'd recognize him if you saw him. Con Rikus.
This guy, right? Very nice this guy. Kind of? No? Uh maybe.
Anyway, he was on the same panel with Ana Kasparian.
And basically Glenn Greenwald's asking him if he thinks Israel
is like he called Glenn Greenwald says Israel's expansionist.
And John goes, "No, no, we're not expansionist. We've been here
forever." And he's like, "Well, what do you think about like
uh does the West is the West Bank going to be part of your homeland?"
And he's like, "Yes, we all of Judea and Samaria, okay? All of
Judea and Samaria belongs to It's like they they don't see it
as them expanding. They see it as them like receiving what was
owed to what what is already there, is right? And stolen from
them. So, it's like not expansion. We are just being give given
back what was taken from us. It's just funny that it's like that's
that's how they see it. Yeah. So, when you say like you're expansionist,
they'll go, "No, we're not doing that. We're like We've It was
literally predetermined. Destined. Gifted to us. Yes. It's like,
But he said it quite proudly. Like he was not hiding it. And
then it's funny then Glenn Greenwald basically accuses him of
like trying to create greater Israel and the Persian person on
the panel just starts shaking her head like that was a stupid
thing for him to say. Like I can't believe you're This guy's
literally sitting here like, "Yes, this is all ours." And she's
like, "Glenn Greenwald is zog posting on this panel. Oh, no."
Hate.
It's like
>> I just find it funny that it's like all these things
that are being called like conspiracies by some people
you talk to like the sincere people in Israel and they're just
like, "Yes, this is what we're doing." Like we're not They're
not like it's not a conspiracy. They're just like, "Yeah, that's
ours. That's what we get. It's ours." Right? Everybody [laughter]
else is like, "You're crazy. You're conspiratorial."
No, he's saying it. He's literally saying it. What are we talking
about?
factors. This is war for Israel. Yeah, go ahead. Oh, sorry. Uh
you're you're also a little bit delayed on your end. Your internet
is cutting in and out a little bit. So, uh I apologize for for
cutting you off.
what I was going to say is um what I was going to say is like
there's there's competing interests here. Uh there's converging
interests and then there's diverging interests. On the American
side and I want to hear your perspective on on my assessment.
Um on the American side, obviously, we have a grand design for
this resource-rich
region. We want to dominate it. We want to have complete control
over OPEC plus to the best of our ability or at least we want
to have like the majority control, right? We We have pliant servile
Gulf states uh and and also completely dominated uh you know,
former states that are now failed states that are puppet states
to the United States of America uh as far as like oil producers.
Uh and we want to be able to control We want to have uh controlling
interest in OPEC plus so that we can use that as a leverage point
against our foreign adversaries, specifically China,
And that's America's interest in the region and Israel has uh
different converging interests with the United States of America
and Israel plays a formative role in this project as a as a you
know unsinkable aircraft carrier as a missile sponge at times
if need be as a you know as a place where we can like
develop our weapons as a as a testing ground for for some of
the latest and greatest technology in terms of conducting warfare
and surveillance and population control but then on top of that
I think Israel's specific interest
>> So Hassan just does this to everybody eh? Doesn't matter
if it's Adam Moller or somebody disagrees with him somebody who
agrees with him. Hassan just kind of
monopolizes the conversation
without really getting to the point too quickly. It's kind of
funny. Beyond being a servant to American empire as a settler
colonial apparatus is this this insane zealotry that they have
in in terms of following this this ultra-Zionist agenda this
His talking made him a millionaire.
idea that they want to complete a greater Israel project destroy
all of the indigenous populations
and either I feel like his talking is not first second or third
greatest attribute. He's not bad at it. He's not like unlistenable
to. It's just sometimes when he's having a conversation with
somebody else he's also far more compelling when it's just When
he's like trying to talk back to somebody else I do think he's
like a little too used to streaming and hearing himself talk.
It's like a lot better when there isn't somebody else in the
conversation who's trying to participate. It's not a collaboration
with Hassan a lot of the time. It's Hassan doing his stream with
another person present. You know what I'm saying? It's like a
little different than a collaborative conversation over
turn them into
you know turn them into slaves or or basically ethnically cleanse
them and and dominate this entire area from Lebanon to Syria
as they've I'll I'll just say I I kind of know why Casey Tron
said what she said, okay? I get it. I get the Casey Tron comment
now, okay?
started taking on even more territory and annexing even more
territory in these places and maybe even parts of Saudi Arabia
and Egypt. And who knows where they go from there, right? And
and definitely even start waging war with Turkey as well once
Iran is is knocked out of the equation is is even Naftali Bennett
has uh clearly signaled, right? >> Ooh. You saw that, right?
The Naftali Bennett stuff?
>> You know what I'm talking about? >> Yeah, I saw
that. I saw that. That was That's crazy that you don't even wait
for this one this target to be down before you're like, "Turkey
is the new Iran." It's so crazy to me, man.
wild stuff. >> The The That's the convergence, but the
divergence I think is when Israel's ambitions get in the way
of of uh a more reasonable path forward. And I think we saw that
as a divergence in the Obama administration. The last time we
had any uh sort of sovereignty in our own design in the Middle
East was the JCPOA.
Now, obviously I have my own personal opinions on uh you know,
developing nuclear sovereignty for nations in the periphery.
I believe everyone has to have a nuclear program if they want
to if they want to exist uh outside of the American nuclear umbrella
as a sovereign state. Having said that, the JCPOA was something
that the Obama administration put together to actually negotiate
uh a a a peaceful path forward with Iran to potentially normalize
relations with Iran, to to have a lot of controls over their
nuclear program and their enrichment capabilities,
um and Israel hated that. And then Donald Trump came into office
and ripped the JCPOA apart. Uh and Iran still continued following
along with the JCPOA for a little bit but then Like at some point
you should pause and just be like are you still following? I
think at any point when you've like realized when you realize
you've talked for like 8 minutes straight in a conversation where
another person
Like it's a little different with Kweiman here cuz I I do expect
to carry my own stream and he just finished streaming. They don't
always try to like go over to him with everything. But like in
a in a collaboration that you're doing like one time I do feel
like if you've just been talking for like 10 minutes straight
you should probably pause and just be like did you have any thoughts
on that? You know what I'm saying? Like he just he is not including
the other guy in the conversation really almost at all. Donald
Trump added additional sanctions. This was Trump one. And then
Joe Biden came into power and Joe Biden was also an ultra Zionist
and Joe Biden also followed with uh the the same exact agenda.
In his own's defense it's only like four or five minutes, okay?
>> I feel like post Trump one Israel got into the driver's
seat and was no longer simply a consultant or no longer simply
uh you know the tip of the spear in some ways uh on America's
Mena policy but basically took it over entirely.
Do you agree with this assessment? I know it's very long. I'm
sorry. Yeah, I mean a couple couple thing couple strings to pull
on from what you you just said. I think there is a a a sort of
uh massive [clears throat] shift in in aspects of uh Trump one
to Trump two. Remember that you know Trump viewed Trump openly
viewed John Bolton, you know one of the most uh obnoxious uh
neocons
uh on the scene. He he openly was talking about what a fanatical
lunatic John Bolton was. And but one of Bolton's kind of crowning
achievements in the first Trump administration when he was the
National Security Advisor was the uh assassination of General
Qassem Soleimani at Baghdad Airport in January of 2020. You know,
the the head of the elite IRGC force of of of Iran. And when
you read some of the reporting about it and even sort of how
Trump spoke about at the time, you know, it took a while for
Trump to come around to that and then ultimately he did it and
then he felt good about it and it kind of showed him his awesome
power and it's like Trump liked those kind of clean things. Oh,
I killed Baghdadi. I killed Qassem Soleimani. But
you know, in general
while Trump was a militaristic president no doubt in his first
term, there was an you got a sense that he he was listening or
sort of leaning more toward the direction of kind of the anti-interventionist
isolationist wing of the MAGA movement. And what's and he's kept
the Israel firster Netanyahu neocon wing kind of a little bit
at bay. He comes in this time and again, the context is Joe Biden,
50-year dedicated Zionist who facilitated the Gaza genocide with
total enthusiasm the you know, throughout his four years in power
and then com-
That's not true. That's not true. That's not true. Joe never
kissed the wall. That's not true.
Benjamin Netanyahu would have lobbied Joe just as hard for going
after Iran. He never would have done it. Harris who comes out
and when she becomes the nominee and says there's nothing I would
do differently than him and that's a huge part of why they lost
of course, but they don't want to release their their autopsy.
Sets the stage then for Trump too and you know, I think one of
the most
Sorry. Obviously the thing I was not disputing that Joe's a Zionist.
Come on. Obviously the thing I was I was disagreeing with was
that he was enthusiastic about the Gaza genocide.
Sorry. That was the That wasn't clear. I Maybe that was I don't
think that was difficult to understand actually. >> to
the questions you're raising in this entire period of Trump's
sec- Come on. >> presidency is when he goes to the Israeli
Knesset
Uh uh back in October when he's on his way to declare he's secured
the Gaza ceasefire at Sharm el-Sheikh, Egypt, and he arrives
in the Knesset, and it was sort of like a reverse Nuremberg trial,
where the war criminals themselves are celebrating themselves
and standing up and cheering one another, and he goes on and
on about the kind of influence of Miriam Adelson, Yeah. Sheldon
Adelson's the late Sheldon Adelson's wife, and the single greatest
bankroller of Trump's campaign. And he talks about her being
the most influential, you know, Israeli in the world. And and
I think that part of what's happened here is that that led up
to this is is is twofold. Trump now is completely
in the service of the most extreme Zionist agenda uh in history.
He's in total servitude to that agenda for a variety of of reasons.
He's not as sophisticated of a of a Zionist as Joe Biden was
when his brain was intact, but Trump is all in, and he's willing
to do anything for them at this point. And then the other component
of it is that these guys are all high on their own supply. You've
got drinking buddy Pete Hegseth as the so-called Secretary of
War. You've got little Marco, who thinks he's Dulles risen from
the dead trying to overthrow Cuba and and and the Venezuela thing.
They they kidnap Maduro, and Trump starts to sort of in want
it injected into his veins. And I was told that that they really
that Trump and his people were saying, "Can we do another Venezuela
in Iran?" And he's hearing from intelligence and military people,
"It doesn't work that way in Iran." And he doesn't like some
of what he's hearing from the military people, and he starts
to understand that, you know, Iran didn't go all in in the last
times that they've struck against us, that their ballistic missiles
are actually uh pretty ferocious in some ways, that there are
uh there are weak links in the Iron Dome system in Israel, that
it can be overwhelmed, that US bases can be hit, that you may,
Mr. President, face a mass casualty incident involving American
personnel. So then they're talking about it was what about a
Libya option where we use air power, but the problem is what
ground forces do you have inside of Iran? And the other thing
is Iran for as much as people talk Are they though? I mean, no,
the ballistic missiles are a problem. Like realistically you
still don't have a slot. I think that what they're Well, no,
the ballistic missiles are a problem and you don't have two aircraft
carriers right there. You understand that, right? That if the
US didn't move forces into the region and those those ballistic
missile platforms were having to be bombed just through Israel's
air force that's flying all the way over Syria and then Iraq.
That would have been a huge problem for them. Yes, that would
have absolutely been a that could have been a massive problem
for them.
That's why they had to move everything >> talk about the
supreme leader, Iran has been building horizontal institutions
since 1979.
This isn't a commentary about any internal political issue. These
are for Iranians to debate. I'm I'm I'm looking at this from
a perspective of uh of of military, intelligence, you know, strategic,
what is possible and what isn't. Iran is not Libya. You know,
Iran is also not Venezuela in in in the sense that you're just
going to lop off the, you know, the the supreme leader and then
say, "We're making a deal with the rest of you." So they they
now are they now are are are in this war that is not in any way
in the interest of the American people whatsoever. It's not in
the interest of anyone in that region except Israel. Um and and
so what do we have at the end of the day? The only conclusion
we can draw is that Trump is fully purchased and bought into
it at the same time Israel's war of annihilations in the region.
You know, I I was in touch with a senior Iranian official this
morning and asked him
The [__]
Oh, hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait,
Wait. Wait, wait, wait.
Dude, I I Do we have to watch this Gavin Newsom thing?
Bro, some crazy quotes coming out of
Oh, this is just talking about it. Hold
So, Newsom is very clearly trying to run trying to own the anti-Israel
lane before 2028. Sure, sure, sure. He apparently is talking
tonight. I looking at this other video that got linked. This
is a video, right?
Oh, is it just No, it's definitely video. Hold on.
This is the thing. They couldn't even I mean, we're talking about
regime change.
For 2 years, they haven't even able to solve the Hamas question.
In Israel.
>> That's a crazy quote. For a guy who's about to run for
president.
You want to go after Iran? How about you solve the Hamas thing,
okay? Why don't you beat Hamas first, blue bro? So, this is I
mean, you know, I I want to be careful here, but you know, in
so many ways, that influence in the context of the conversation
of where Trump ultimately landed on this is pretty damn
They couldn't even I mean, we're talking about regime change.
For 2 years, they haven't even able to solve the Hamas question.
The HQ, they say.
Lee loses DGG. Suddenly, every DGGer is like, you know what?
Hasan might have had a point. I don't think I can stand behind
this guy. I'm not sure I can commit to voting for this guy anymore,
okay? Hasan might have been Listen, we got to give Hasan his
his laurels on that, okay? Okay.
I don't know if I can stand behind this guy. This guy's kind
of crazy, man.
Is this interview out somewhere? That looks like the Pod Save
America guys, right?
Yeah, it's the Pod Save guys.
Where is this Where did this conversation happen? Yeah, Jon Favreau,
Tommy Tommy Vietor.
An evening with Gavin Newsom. Really? HQ posting HQ on main.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
HQ posting on Maine.
The Hamas question. Oh, the response from all of these uh Arab
countries where they're condemning   Iranian
aggression, but then they're silent.
Do you think DG Uh Missy, the unfortunate thing is is I think
a big part of those audiences are only there because of their
support for Israel right now. I do
How do I put this? I
I don't know how I'm going to keep this Lonerbox bridge intact
at all, to be honest with you.
Feel like I hang out in Lonerbox's community and it's like not
I If I'm in the VC, I'm not hearing a lot of pro-Palestine stuff.
Is like
how I think it goes, which is weird. I asked them outright at
the other day I was sitting there and just listening to talk
and I'm like, "Bro, how hard did David win?" Like I know David,
the guy who's like the super Zionist DG Gear.
I was like, "Dude, how hard did he win?" He I thought he's going
to get Are they all just like that? Are they all just dog bots
who are just like screeching about No, no. There are lots of
very smart people, but like it feels like You know how You know
how there are people who are like totally like completely pro-Palestine,
like hardcore, right? And then there are people on the other
side and then those people fight and there'd be people in the
middle. Feels like all of those hardcore people are gone on the
pro-Palestine side and there's no people in the middle. Sorry,
there's people Sorry, the people in the middle just don't really
comment.
Is how it feels.
How it felt, but I I mean I'm only there for a little bit of
the day. Like a certain tiny slice of the day. So maybe there
are a lot of really pro-Palestine people who come in. But like
I thought it was the opposite before, that it was like really
heavy pro-Palestine
with like David getting massive pushback for being pro-Zionist
like unapologetically.
So I don't know if that shift took place. I don't know, maybe
it's the community mirroring Lonerbox's shift or something. I
do think like the the heart But I'm not saying that they're like
right. I'm just saying there's like more extreme pro-Zionist
people, what like. And like I felt like I was giving voice to
something that they
don't necessarily hear all the time.
Anyway, it's it was interesting.
Um yeah.
Letterboxd berates anyone's profile sign. Does he berate them?
Does he really berate them?
He might berate the I He might berate the more extreme people.